où la majorité des américains sont
sympathisants de ces mobilisations
ils savent qu'il y à de la violence
policière et ils veulent que ces
violences cessent selon vous 99% de la
police qui est impliqué dans une
fusillade n'est jamais condamné est ce
qu'il ya une impunité assumer il y a une
culture de l'impunité dans la police
américaine
le problème c'est le système
institutionnel et c'est pour ça que même
après avoir eu un président noir
cela continue finalement les gens
demandent une justice sociale autant
qu'une justice raciale mais également
économique
[Musique]
plusieurs milliers de personnes à nantes
pour une marche blanche à la mémoire de
steve mailhac et nice au le jeune homme
décédé suite à une intervention
policière le soir de la fête de la
musique premier anniversaire de sa
disparition dans la loire une
mobilisation pour dénoncer les violences
et pour réclamer justice selon les
organisateurs premier grand meeting de
campagne pour donald trump 7 et hier
soir à tulsa en oklahoma
un discours de deux heures loin de la
foule des grands jours ses opposants
démocrates auraient réservé des places
sans avoir l'intention de s'y rendre
le chef de l'état a fustigé son
adversaire en le qualifiant de
marionnettes de la gauche radicale
[Musique]
terminées les restrictions de
déplacement en espagne alors que le
virus s'étend en amérique latine plus
d'un million de cas déclarés au brésil
nouvel épicentre de la pandémie le cap
des vingt mille morts franchi au mexique
le virus circule toujours un peu par
tout le monde est entré dans une phase
dangereuse selon l'organisation mondiale
de la santé
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce dimanche une marche
blanche aujourd'hui à nantes en loire
atlantique pour steve mailhac à nice aux
sept animateurs périscolaire de 24 ans
qui a disparu l'an dernier le soir de la
fête de la musique
ils étaient venus danser sur les bords
de loire et a disparu au cours d'une
opération policière
son corps a été retrouvé un mois plus
tard dans le fleuve
plusieurs milliers de personnes sont
venues vous le voyez lui rendre hommage
et dénoncer les violences policières
on va prendre tout de suite la direction
de nantes pour retrouver notre reporter
terre katia pique nique un bon soir
katia vous avez suivi cette marche
blanche aujourd'hui et il y avait du
monde
qui vais énormément non des milliers des
milliers de personnes une ambiance
presque familiale d'une part évidemment
il y avait la famille de steve qui était
bien sûr très éprouvés mais aussi des
parents qui sont venus avec leurs
enfants et des jeunes de jeunes des
soutiens mais aussi des amis de steve le
moddeur c'était de rester dans un
rassemblement pacifique et il ya eu
aucun débordement une présence policière
discrète présente bien sûr mais en tout
cas tout s'est passé de manière très
calme du point de départ qui se trouvait
au château des ducs sur jusqu'à le
jusqu'au quai wilson qui est l'endroit
où steve a trouvé la mort en tombant
dans la loire à moment au moment d'une
intervention policière je vous propose
d'écouter deux amis de steve mann on est
mal que nous avons interviewé juste
avant le départ du cortège non veux pas
qu'ils aient de deux slogans aussi
police ou des trucs comme ça on est
vraiment dans un but tout c'est rendre
hommage à steve et c'est tout si on
voulait faire des manifestations anti
police ça ferait bien longtemps qu'on
leur ait fait on serait déjà le samedi
alors qu'on voit pas du tout nos têtes
on n'y est pas donc voilà en état
d'esprit de solidarité
familial aussi ce que c'est quand même
un contexte familial qui est puissant
nous les amis aussi on est très soudés
ensemble
du coup on aimerait vraiment de la
solidarité du pacifisme donc il n'y a
pas eu de slogans anti police 1 durant
le rassemblement mais plutôt justice
pour steve
en effet les deux enquêtes
administratives qui existe pour le
moment ont plus ou moins des douanes et
la police
évidemment quand comme on sait que le
téléphone de steve à borner à 4h33 c'est
à dire après la les premières recherches
policières à base de lacrymogènes et de
grenades
il ya tout lieu de s'interroger donc
c'est maintenant l affaire est entre les
mains de la justice puisque trois
plaintes ont été déposées
cette manifestation au son de la musique
techno capac affectionnez
particulièrement le jeune homme s'est
achevée après des prises de parole une
minute de silence et des danses aussi
des danses lente à la mémoire du jeune
homme
et maintenant il y aura d'autres
rassemblements alors derrière moi une un
dispositif policier pour pour empêcher
les jeunes gens de se ressembler il ya
eu ici au quai de la fosse déjà des
dispersions de deux jeunes de l'autre
côté aussi des personnes qui s'étaient
rassemblées ont voulu passer pour
évidemment faire un rassemblement plus
grand mais ils ont été bloqués donc
toute la ville à certains endroits est
un peu bloquée mais on sait d'ores et
déjà que d'autres rassemblements vont
avoir lieu c'est un peu le jeu du chat
et de la souris avec les forces de
l'ordre et donc nous suivons la
situation ici à nantes
merci beaucoup catia pour toutes ces
précisions katia technique en direct de
nantes et on n'est qu'au justement à ce
rassemblement
quelques dizaines de personnes se sont
donné rendez vous place de l'étoile à
paris pour rendre également hommage à ce
jeune homme décédé
et parmi elle a certes un gilet jaune
comme l'avocat david libeskind écoutez
le je crois qu'il est c'est
l'anniversaire qu'il faut commémorer
puisqu'aujourd'hui on parle depuis des
mois et des mois de violences policières
et donc je pense que c'est un événement
important voilà fois
votre là pour lui faut montrer qu'on l'a
pas oublié on sait pas où en est
l'enquêté
gpn l enquête judiciaire actuel on
espère que ça va donner des résultats
parce qu'il ya des pressions faites par
les organisations de droits de l'homme
et des différents comités bas sur la
justice pour que pour que ça avance mais
aujourd'hui on n'a pas de nouvelles
voilà on attend toujours normal qu'on
puisse au moins lui rendre hommage et
être présent même si c'est que quelques
minutes pour quelqu'un qui a disparu
alors qu'il n'a rien fait juste pour la
fête de la musique c'est un jour pour
faire la fête et malheureusement on
disparaît parce qu'on fait la fête
c'est malheureux de voir ça dans un dans
le pays des droits de l'homme
pour nous c'est comme si c'était hier on
n'oublie pas ça on oublie pas et on
lâchera pas il était trop jeune pour
mourir ce ce garçon il était là pour
s'amuser et est là pour ça pour rigoler
comme n'importe quel enfant comme
n'importe quel garçon n'importe quel
jeune il n'arrête pas d'humour ce genre
là et la police devrait se remettre en
question et sur le plan politique en
france le second tour de l'élection
municipale c'est dans une semaine
dimanche
exactement et il reste à élire les
maires de 5000 communes ce qui n'avait
pas pu être élu dès le premier tour le
15 mars dernier un premier tour en
pleine crise sanitaire qui a largement
été critiquée par certains partis
politiques
voyez ce qu'en pense hervé marseille à
sénateurs udi des hauts-de-seine et
fabien roussel secrétaire nationale du
parti communiste français et député de
la 20e circonscription du nord ce que
nous mettons en avant
ce sont des villes citoyenne solidaire
écologistes ce sont des villes qui par
exemple mettre en place des centres
municipaux de santé faisant en sorte que
tous les citoyens d'une ville est accès
à une médecine de proximité proximité ce
sont des villes où nous nous battons
pour l'accès à des transports les moins
chers possibles voire gratuit à chaque
fois que c'est possible
nous voulons apporter notre contribution
contre la pollution pour le climat avec
des transports gratuits partout
le chef de l'état un français sommé
d'agir rapidement contre les inégalités
dans une tribune publiée aujourd'hui une
quarantaine de
personnalité réclame six mesures
d'urgence pour combler les retards du
service public dans les territoires
populaire et en particulier en seine
saint denis qui est le département le
plus pauvre de métropole des territoires
qui ont payé le prix fort de la crise
pour les morts et pour les premiers de
corvée insistent les signataires ainsi
des élus de gauche des sportifs ou
encore des médecins ont listé six
mesures à appliquer en urgence voyez ce
qu'en pense christophe prudhomme il est
médecin urgentiste au samu responsable
cgt et signataires de cette tribune et
j'ai nous sommes inquiets pour savoir si
nous allons réussir à passer l'été si on
a un second appel canicule c'est à dire
de forte chaleur ce qui est habituel
pendant l'été
nous allons être en grande difficulté le
personnel hospitalier est épuisé nous
avons encore des collègues qui sont en
arrêt maladie
nous manquons de lits donc il ya urgence
et vous savez là le gouvernement depuis
un mois nous amuse avec son secteur de
la santé nous n'avons aucune proposition
concrète le gouvernement ment comme il a
menti pendant la crise sur les masques
sur les tests vous avez vu un bleu l'un
le directeur général de la santé devant
la commission d'enquêté parlementaire
qui ment aussi il faut aujourd'hui un
langage de vérité
walt roman il se pose un problème avec
ce gouvernement quelle est la légitimité
aujourd'hui ce gouvernement si nous
avons de nouveau des ministres des hauts
fonctionnaires qui continue à mentir y
compris devant une commission d enquête
parlementaire
voilà pour qu'ils arrêtent car la
réalité de terrain c'est celle que le
dénonçons réouverture des frontières en
espagne depuis la nuit dernière minuit
les voyageurs en provenance de l'union
européenne peuvent de nouveau entrer
dans le pays
terminé l'état d' alerte décrété le 14
mars dernier ainsi que la quarantaine de
deux semaines pour les étrangers qui
arrivent sur le sol espagnol
les espagnols eux cantonnée jusqu'ici à
leur province peuvent de nouveau
circuler librement sur tout le
territoire
une seule exception la frontière avec le
portugal elle reste fermée jusqu'au 1er
juillet la vigilance néanmoins reste de
mise c'est ce qu'a dit le premier
ministre espagnol
j'aimerais vous dire que nous ne pouvons
pas baisser la garde
nous
rester sur nos gardes également d'un
point de vue institutionnel et suivre
strictement les mesures d'hygiène et de
protection
surtout avec la plus grande
responsabilité dont nous avons fait
preuve jusqu'à présent nous pouvons être
chacun un mur contre le virus ou en
moyens de contagion cela dépend de
chacun d'entre nous une réouverture qui
réjouit bon nombre de français qui
vivent près de la frontière ibérique est
déjà nombreux à s'y rendre pour du
shopping du tourisme regardez je suis
allé en espagne faire des courses
alimentaires faire un peu de gasoil par
la même occasion
et puis quelques cigarettes pareil pour
faire les boutiques et apprendre entre
dédramatise un petit peu parce que c'est
vrai qu'avec la fermeture des frontières
on était un peu tout ce qu'ils hall et
du coup ça nous permet un petit peu de
revivre en prenant en compte la pandémie
et puis les gestes barrière à respecter
avec le masque obligatoire à cuire
et puis le gel hydroalcoolique
obligatoire et alors que l'espagne a
rouvert ses frontières aujourd'hui le
virus lui s'étend en amérique latine au
mexique le cap des vingt mille morts a
été franchi conséquence le pays repousse
d'une semaine la réouverture de ces
cafés et de ses restaurants dans la
capitale
cinquante mille décès au au brésil c'est
le nouvel épicentre de la pandémie avec
plus d'un million de cas déclarés alors
qu'ils sont en première ligne dans cette
crise sanitaire comme partout d'ailleurs
un médecin infirmiers et personnels
hospitaliers vous voyez sont descendus
dans les rues de rio pour manifester
hier ils réclament le paiement de leurs
salaires qui a été suspendue pour
certains par le gouvernement le mois
dernier écoutez le gouvernement de
l'état de rio de janeiro ne finance pas
beaucoup d'organisations sociales mais
des entreprises privées sont engagés
pour travailler dans les hôpitaux les
services d'urgence et les services
d'ambulance
plus précisément nous avons trois
organisations sans salaire et le service
d'ambulance mobile le samu et le
quatrième serait préférable pour moi
d'aller dans une institution privée pour
faire ce travail
mais ici au brésil nous savons que la
population est très peu suivie avec
beaucoup de besoins
il ya des gens dans des conditions
misérables à l'intérieur des quartiers
pauvres et malheureusement je ne peux
pas arrêter de les aider c'est un
travail que je fais avec beaucoup
d'amour et d'attention est toujours au
brésil une communauté indigène situé en
amazonie au croisement au croisement de
trois frontières tente de lutter par ses
propres moyens contre le virus
voyez le récit de medias kéfi
particulièrement touché par la crise
sanitaire les communautés autochtones
doivent s'adapter pour éviter une
propagation massive dans leurs rangs les
membres de la réserve du maria coup en
plein coeur de l'amazonie brésilienne
contrôler rigoureusement les entrées
dans leur village on a des gens qui ont
eu la maladie mais personne n'en est
mort jusqu'à aujourd'hui la pandémie
nous a sérieusement impacté et pas juste
un peu parce que les gens ont accès à
cette ville et il ya un autre pays
voisin qui est la colombie ces gens
viennent de colombie ses proches c'est à
15 minutes
ils viennent ici pour acheter nos
produits du poisson des fruits et
d'autres choses comparables à d'autres
frappés clouté par des fiascos un
problème les contrôles sont
particulièrement difficiles à mettre en
place la ville de tabac qinghai située à
la frontière colombienne mais aussi
péruvienne la communauté a donc établi
des règles sanitaires strictes en raison
des nombreux allers et venues une
personne a dit gêne au saindoux maria
coup ne peut pas non plus sortir sans en
porter un masque si elle arrive à la
barre hier sans masque on lui dit de
rentrer mettre un masque pour pouvoir
sortir parce qu'ils vont quitter les
terres indigènes et faire la queue à la
banque à la loterie
ils iront marché on conseille aussi aux
personnes indigènes en plus les port du
masque le respecter des distances de
sécurité dans les zones densément
peuplées
toujours dans un souci d'anticiper des
contaminations
ces indigènes ont mis en place un
système de soins mélange entre tradition
et médecine occidentale
[Musique]
pour l'instant on prend soin de nous
avec des remèdes traditionnels et des
médicaments occidentaux prescrits par
des infirmiers et des médecins
selon l'association des peuples
indigènes près de 6000 membres des
communautés autochtones ont été
contaminées par le commis de 19 et plus
de 300 ont déjà perdu la vie des suites
de la maladie
deux mille morts supplémentaires en inde
cette semaine à cause du virus depuis
vendredi les habitants de chennai c'est
dans le sud du pays sont à nouveau
assignée à résidence pour 12 jours
et puis la chine également qui connaît
une hausse des contaminations qui craint
un pékin qui craint une nouvelle vague
les autorités chinoises sont aujourd'hui
sur le prime
voyez les précisions nilan a fait
radian6 mois après l'apparition du coït
la crainte d'une deuxième vague se
précise en asie ce mercredi
l'inde a annoncé une hausse brutale des
contaminations et plus de 2000 morts en
un jour une hausse due à la révision des
chiffres à bombay ville la plus touchée
du pays de marsabit mets tout mon
personnel a effectué un travail
d'assainissement pour contenir le kovy
19 à bombay depuis le 16 mai nous avons
entrepris un véritable travail de
contrôle des vecteurs du paludisme de la
dengue est aussi de la leptospirose
il s'agit d'une double charge pour le
département et les employés qui sont
affectés à cette tâche déjà à court de
lits et de personnel soignant
le pays s'apprête aussi à réquisitionner
hôtels et autres salles de réception
pour y installer d'éventuels hôpitaux de
campagne
et si la situation sanitaire venait à se
dégrader la mousson qui dure de juin à
septembre ne devrait rien arranger
pour rappel chaque année plus d'un demi
million d'indiens sont contaminés par
des maladies favorisée par les pluies
comme la dengue et le paludisme des
infections qui présentent des symptômes
quasi identiques à ceux du coc vite 19
de la fièvre des difficultés à respirer
ou encore une perte d'appétit
cette année nous avons plus peur que
d'habitude car chaque année pendant les
meneurs sont des maladies comme la
dengue et le paludisme se répandent la
population de moustiques augmente
également pendant la mousson et cette
année j'ai plus peur à cornell
et parce que les chances d'attraper un
rhume sont plus élevés pendant la
mousson et l'inde n'est pas le seul pays
du continent asiatique à redouter cette
fameuse deuxième vague
confronté à de nouvelles contaminations
la chine a lancé lundi une campagne de
dépistage massive est confiné plusieurs
zones résidentielles de pékin toutes les
écoles ont été fermées tandis que dans
les aéroports de nombreux vols au départ
et à l'arrivée de la capitale du pays
ont été annulés premier grand meeting de
campagne pour donald trump c'était hier
soir à tulsa en oklahoma un discours de
deux heures loin de la foule des grands
jours ses opposants démocrates auraient
réservé des places sans avoir
l'intention de s'y rendre
du coup la salle était à moitié vide le
chef de l'état qui a fustigé son
adversaire joe biden il la traitait de
marionnettes de la gauche radicale
grégoire doucet
[Musique]
réalisée moins de tests pour ralentir le
nombre de cases avérée voilà la
stratégie prônée par le président
américain ce samedi lors de son meeting
comme souvent difficile d'affirmer s'il
s'agit d'un calcul teintée d'ironie ou
de propos sérieux de la part du
milliardaire donald trump qui a signé un
retour attendu par ses partisans
si l'affluence n'était pas à la hauteur
des attentes de son équipe de campagne
il était tout de même plusieurs milliers
à venir afficher leur soutien dans la
ville de tall ça dans l'oklahoma
nous commençons notre campagne et je
voulais juste tous vous remercier vous
êtes des guerriers
lorsque vous faites autant de tests vous
allez trouver plus de gens affectés
vous allez trouver plus de cas j'ai donc
dit à mes collaborateurs
s'il vous plaît ralentissent et les
tests ils font des tests et encore des
tests nous avons eu des tests où les
gens ne savaient pas ce qui se passait
nous avons fait des tests nous en avons
un autre ici le jeune garçon qui a 10
ans qui a le nez qui coule
il s'en remettra une quinzaine de
minutes plus tard c'est un cas c'est un
cas un tel rassemblement est toujours
redoutée en raison des risques accrus de
propagation du coronavirus dernier
sanders s'est indigné de l'organisation
de cet événement selon le sénateur du
vermont
trump est prêt à propager le coc vite 19
juste pour entendre quelques
acclamations
six personnes parmi les organisateurs
ont d'ailleurs été testée positive avant
le meeting est immédiatement placé en
quarantaine à sur l'équipe de campagne
si le pays déplore près de 120 mille
décès liés à la maladie le président
américain a défendu coûte que coûte son
bilan à propos de cette crise le coc
vite 19
ce nom s'éloigne de plus en plus de la
chine alors qu'on l'appelait le virus
chinois
le fait que non moi avons fait un
travail phénoménal avec ce virus j'ai
fermé les états unis à une population
très fortement affecté notamment à tous
les gens venant de chine à la fin
janvier
c'est à dire des mois plus tôt que ce
que d'autres personnes aurait fait s'il
avait fait j'ai sauvé les centaines de
milliers de vies on n'en parle même pas
entre des sondages en berne la sortie
imminente du livre à charge contre lui
signé par son ex conseiller à la
sécurité john bolton ou encore les
nombreuses manifestations hostiles à sa
politique
le président des états unis traversent
une période difficile
il lui reste cinq mois pour renverser la
vapeur et briguer un second mandat
le discours du président trump analysés
par taoufik jebali il est maître de
conférences en civilisation américaine
écoutez c'est c'est une campagne qui bas
de laine et je crois que ça commençait
déjà depuis le mois de février trempe
avait insisté pour mettre fin au
confinement pour commencer sa campagne
et comprenez bien que il fallait
absolument commencer cette campagne lui
prendre son adversaire de vitesse
finalement je crois que c'est un
rassemblement
raté il y avait toujours du monde en a
il y avait à peu près dix mille
personnes ce sont des purs et durs qui
aurait dans tous les cas on soutenu 30
c'est un public plutôt d'extrême droite
c'est un public blanc c'est un public
extrêmement conservateur qui de toute
façon soutiendrait trempe donc tous les
cas et dans toutes les situations donc
ça cinq ans servent essentiellement sens
en khl et sans public qui ne suivent et
qui le serait de toute façon
et en marge de ce premier discours de
campagne des soutiens du président
américain et des militants entier
racistes se sont retrouvés vous loyer au
même moment dans le centre de la ville
de tulle ça et si les deux camps se sont
fait face pendant plusieurs minutes
aucun débordement ni affrontements n'ont
été signalés au royaume uni au lendemain
de l'attaqué au couteau à reading qui a
fait trois morts la police britannique a
confirmé aujourd'hui le caractère
terroriste de cette attente à
l'assaillant est un homme de 25 ans
d'origine libyenne arrivée sur le sol
britannique sous le statut de réfugié
politique
il a été placé en garde à vue et hier
vers 19 heures il s'en est donc pris à
des passants dans un parc de la ville de
red line dans la banlieue de londres
cette attaque a également fait 3 blessés
graves et c'est un choc pour cette
petite ville de 200000 habitants écoutez
cela semble vraiment tragique c'est le
genre de chose qui se produit beaucoup
en ce moment j'ai l'impression que ça
fait fréquemment les gros titres
c'est assez épouvantable encore des
coups de couteau c'est vraiment mauvais
et bien c'est terrible que ces jeunes
aient perdu la vie c'est terrible et
nous devrions vraiment aller au fond des
problèmes sociaux qui sont réellement la
cause de tout cela c'est quelque chose
d'assez inhabituel à reading et je dois
dire que je pense à ceux qui sont
touchés et que c'est un événement
choquant et très triste dans notre ville
je pense que nous devons simplement
montrer notre soutien aux personnes qui
ont été touchées et aussi rester calme
et continuer comme nous le faisons dans
notre communauté
en nous soutenant les uns les autres et
en étant un lieu de vie cohésif et
amicale
ce que nous sommes et ce n'est pas la
première fois que la grande bretagne
subit ce type d' attaques terroristes au
couteau vous voyez ce qu'on dit cet
ancien policier britannique et son
spin-off conson fessenheim
c'est un sujet de préoccupation depuis
un certain temps sur la manière dont on
réagit aux attaques terroristes dans des
lieux
comme le centre de londres ou de
manchester est souvent considérée comme
impeccable est vraiment rapide
il ya normalement beaucoup d'agents de
police qui interviennent en cas
d'infraction ils parviennent à y mettre
un terme rapidement mais ce n'est pas le
cas pour les petites villes et villages
au royaume uni dans ces régions la
police ne dispose pas d'autant de
ressources
il ya beaucoup moins de policiers pour
des régions pourtant nettement plus
grande
mais une intervention en cas d' alerte
serait donc lente par définition il y
aurait moins de policiers sur une scène
d'infraction
dans le cas de reading il semble que
l'agresseur aurait attaqué des personnes
dans un parc
après quoi elle serait sortie du parc et
aurait été peu après interpellés par les
policiers qui sont arrivés sur place
donc quoi qu'il en soit l'auteur de
l'attaqué a été rapidement neutralisé en
libye et l'egypte menacé d'intervenir
militairement pour soutenir les troupes
du maréchal haftar ces rebelles qui
perdent du terrain face aux forces du
gouvernement libyen d'union nationale
ils ont remporté une série de deux
victoires dans la région de tripoli
depuis quelques mois et cela grâce au
soutien militaire de la turquie et des
soldats qui avance dangereusement vers
la ville stratégique de syrte
et attention à ne pas franchir la ligne
rouge a averti l'egypte hélène masquer
des berceaux de la famille kadhafi et
ancien bastion des champs libye la ville
côtière de syrte constitue un verrou
stratégique dans le conflit qui oppose
le gn à aux troupes du maréchal haftar
une cité qui se trouve à la porte des
plus importantes installations
pétrolières et qui ouvre la voie à une
conquête de l'est du pays qui possèdent
une frontière de plus de 1000 km avec
l'egypte franchir la ligne de syrte et
d'al joufra c'est pour nous la ligne
rouge
l'intervention directe de l'état
égyptien est devenu légitime au niveau
international que ce soit d'après la
charte des nations unies ou sur la base
de la seule autorité légitime élu par le
peuple libyen
l'objectif de l'intervention sera de
protéger et de sécuriser les frontières
de l'egypte à l'ouest
avec son étendue stratégique contre la
menace des milices terroristes et des
mercenaires
depuis plusieurs mois le conflit libyen
connaît une implication croissante de
puissances étrangères
rallye faf tard principal opposant du
gouvernement basé à tripoli est appuyé
par les émirats arabes unis l'arabie
saoudite ou encore l'egypte tandis que
le gn a reconnu par les nations unies et
soutenue militairement par la turquie le
jeune a estimé nous le soutenons cela
que toutes les parties doivent retourner
à leur position de 2015 lorsque l'accord
politique libyen de skhirat a été signé
ce qui veut dire que les forces de la
star doivent se retirer de syrte et d'al
joufra telle est la position du gn à nos
gouvernements libyen d'union nationale
actuellement en position de force
accusera l'ifa haftar de vouloir gagner
du temps et dénonce la volonté
d'ingérence du caire dans le dossier
libyen et on se quitte maintenant sur
ces images cette éclipse solaire très
rare voyez vous le voyez c'était la nuit
dernière à hong kong
un phénomène également visible depuis
les pays du golfe depuis l'afrique qui
ne se produit qu'une seule fois voire
deux fois par an
un peu de nuages malheureusement et
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
votre fidélité on se retrouve dans 30
minutes rester avec nous
[Musique]
m
elle
je
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à